Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a comedy-drama film
called “Hichki”. Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
Naina is a woman in her twenties
looking to get a job as a teacher.
She has a Bachelor's degree in Education
and a Master's degree in Science,
making her the perfect candidate academically.
However, her biggest drawback in life is that she
has Tourette's syndrome. This causes her to make
uncontrollable noises that sound like hiccups.
Since she can hardly keep quiet because of
it, the interviewers believe that she is
unfit to be a teacher. Naina has been trying to
get a job for the past five years but to no luck.
She is now working as a freelance animator but
hasn’t given up on finding a job as a teacher.
Naina lives with her mother and younger brother
Vinay, both of whom support her unconditionally.
A flashback shows us that when Naina was in middle
school, she used to be made fun of all the time.
The teachers didn’t understand that her
condition was uncontrollable and sent her
outside the class when she made a noise.
This had a huge effect on her mental health
and she could hardly make friends. She was
transferred from twelve schools and was told to go
to the school for children with special needs. But
Naina’s mother Sudha was adamant about giving her
daughter a normal life. The same cannot be said
for her father Sachin. He divorced Sudha after
finding out that Naina had Tourette's and was
never present for the first few years of her life.
He tried to bond with his children over the years
but every time they went out, he was embarrassed
of Naina. He also urged Sudha to send her to
a special needs school but she didn’t give up
on her daughter. The day Naina found out that her
parents divorced because of her, she shoved toilet
paper into her mouth to try to prevent the noises.
She wanted to be liked by her father so badly that
she blamed herself for not being good enough.
Currently, Sachin does his best to be present in
his children’s lives but Naina doesn’t welcome
him. He doesn’t support her dreams and wants her
to take an easy banking job. One day, they get
into an argument about the matter when suddenly,
Naina gets a call from her former school,
St. Notker's. They ask her to come in for
a second interview, claiming that she has
gotten the job. A high school teacher at
St. Notker resigned mid-term, leaving the
school’s board desperate for a new candidate.
Although Naina was not their first choice,
they had to hire her for the time being.
She goes for a follow-up interview with
the dean and fellow teachers. They are
all skeptical because of obvious reasons but
Naina’s spirit impresses them. When asked why
she wants to be a teacher, she replies that
after being kicked out of twelve schools,
she was accepted by St. Notker's, all thanks to
her former teacher Mr. Ali. A flashback shows us
little Naina watching a drama performance
during a school function. While everyone
in the audience watches in silence, she cannot
help but make noise because of her Tourette.
They look at her annoyed when the school’s
principal Mr. Ali calls her to the stage.
He makes her explain her condition to the audience
and asks her what they can do to help her. After
listening to her story, the teachers of the
school understand her condition much better
and help her accordingly. Back in the interview,
she praises Mr. Ali, claiming that she wants to
be a teacher because of him. Impressed with the
answer, the dean welcomes her to the school. But
a fellow teacher named Wadia bluntly declares that
it is a bad decision. The dean shows Naina around
the school and tells her that she is supposed to
teach class 9F, the students with the worst grades
in the school. On her first day at the job, Naina
goes to the auditorium, reminiscing about the day
she was called to the stage. The students of class
9F enter the room but do not notice her. They
talk in foul street language and start smoking
cigarettes. Some of them play with their pet mice,
while the others play cards. They also talk
about Naina, calling her names and making
fun of her hiccups like Tourette's. Naina
hears them but doesn’t confront them.
Later, she meets the students for the first
time and welcomes them to her class. Like she
had thought, they make fun of her hiccups and call
her names. Their leader Aatish makes inappropriate
comments about wanting to call Naina at night.
Still, when the students laugh, she laughs with
them, not showing that their words affect her.
She also explains to them what Tourettes is. The
students realise that she heard their conversation
earlier and go quiet. But moments later,
they burst into laughter when Naina falls from
a broken chair while trying to sit on it. During
the lunch break, one of the school’s top-scoring
students, Akshay gets into an argument with Aatish
about a punctured football. They get into a fight
but only Aatish is taken to the dean’s office.
The following day, Naina meets the school’s
janitor and asks him the history of class 9F.
She finds out that everyone in class 9F lives
in a nearby slum in poverty. They were granted
admission to the prestigious school because their
old municipal school was under heavy debt.
They had been promised good education but instead,
they faced prejudice from the teachers and the
wealthy students. With time, they retaliated and
became the people they are today. After finding
out the truth, Naina is determined to help them
even more. But the students do not cooperate.
They never pay attention when she is teaching, and
prank her every day. One time, they even go as far
as to paste her picture and phone number around
the neighborhood, advertising her as a sex worker.
When Naina walks into the class the next morning,
she sees a bucket. On looking closer, it explodes
and breaks the glass window. The students are
about to be expelled from the school because of
the pranks but Naina takes the blame on herself.
Claiming that the explosion was her fault,
she asks the dean to give them one more chance.
When he tells her that the kids have no future,
Naina insists that if they do not score good
results in the final exam, she will admit that she
was wrong and the students will be expelled.
The dean agrees and gives her four months' time
to prove herself. Following that, she comes to the
classroom to the students who are grateful that
she helped them. It is foreign to them because
no teacher of the school had treated them with
respect till now. Starting the next day, the
students pay attention to when she teaches
and get along with her. Naina uses various
innovative techniques to keep them entertained.
She even holds classes on the ground and
throws boiled eggs at them to explain about
a parabola. All this time, Wadia watches her,
unimpressed by her teaching techniques. He is
hoping for her downfall because he despises
the students of 9F. In one of the classes,
the students complain that they are never
considered for eligibility to be in the school’s
prefect’s team. Naina takes their concern to the
dean and is told that a student has to score more
than ninety percent to be eligible. Waida laughs
at the thought of her students scoring that high
but Naina takes on the challenge.
The next week, the school holds a parents’
teachers’ meeting. While all other teachers are
busy talking to the parents, Naina sits idle the
entire time. Since the parents of the students
in 9F are busy trying to make minimum wage daily,
they hardly get time to be involved in their
children’s lives. Naina takes it upon herself
to go to the slums and meet the parents.
The lifestyle of the people living there,
makes her realize why the students have such a
hard time focusing on their studies. The kids
and their parents have to wait in line for hours
just to get a bucket of water. The family barely
earns enough to make a living, let alone to
invest on better stationeries for the kids.
In the next class, Naina asks the kids to write
down a list of things that they are scared of.
After they are done, she asks them to use the list
as a way of letting go of the fear. The students
tear the page and make paper airplanes with them.
Wadia finds one of the papers and laughs at what
is written on it. Naina teaches the students
in a way that actually interests them. Even
the students of class 9A are jealous of the fun
experiments that she lets the children perform.
Wadia and his students are preparing a project
for the national science fair. St. Notker has
won for the last two years, hence, Waida is hoping
for a third win. One day, the topper, Natasha
invites Aatish and the group to give them a tour
of their project. By this time, the students of 9F
are just as good in their studies as the others.
They even suggest innovative changes that could
be done to the project. However, when Waida finds
out they are messing with it, he insults Aatish
calling him a mere bicycle mechanic.
Later, Aatish says offensive things to Akshay
to pick a fight with him. They almost hit each
other and have to be separated by Naina. Aatish
calls her an animal from a circus, making fun
of her Tourettes. Naina almost hits him but
controls herself. That evening, she goes to
dinner with her family for her brother’s birthday.
Her father Sachin orders for her when she takes
time to do so because of her Tourettes. It is
clear that he is embarrassed by her which causes
tension between the two yet again. The next day,
Akshay presents their project to the school
teachers to practice for the science fair.
However, the working model explodes in the middle
of it. Wadia apologizes to everyone for the
inconvenience, disappointed that they do not have
enough time to prepare a new model. On checking
what is wrong with the model, he finds a vial of
glue that he had seen with Aatish earlier.
It is clear that Aatish messed with the model
to destroy it. When he is called out for it, the
entire class joins him, claiming that they helped
him do it, even though it was only his plan.
The dean is about to expel the entire class now
that they have crossed a line. But Naina begs for
him to let them take the exam because their future
depends on it. In the end, they are suspended from
attending school until the exams. The students
are furious at Aatish for breaking Niana’s trust.
That night, they gather by the bank of a river
and decide that even if they cannot go to school,
they will study hard for the exams and make their
teacher proud. The next day, they visit Naina and
apologize for everything they have done till now.
Sachin sees this and is proud of his daughter for
the first time in his life. He also starts
to respect her as a person, realizing that
he was in fact ashamed of her till now.
For the next few weeks, the students do nothing
but study. Naina invites them to her house almost
every day for group studies. She also provides
them with required stationeries, preparing
them for the exam. The day before the exam,
the school’s janitor offers to sell the question
papers to Aatish. He buys it from him and tries to
give it to the others. However, they do not want
to cheat because that would mean betraying Naina.
The morning of the exam, Aatish realizes
that the question papers he was provided with
were fake. Still, the students do their
best and score passing marks. One of them,
named Oru, scores the highest marks, surpassing
everyone from class 9A. On doing some digging,
Wadia finds out about the leaked question
papers and accuses everyone from 9F of cheating.
The janitor affirms that he sold the papers.
The dean cannot excuse their actions anymore.
He decides to expel everyone from the
class in the morning assembly.
The students apologize to Naina for letting
her down but insist that they did not cheat.
Naina believes them but she has no way to prove
the same to the others. Then, we see Akshay and
Wadia walking down the hallway. Akshay reveals
that he was the one who sent the janitor to sell
Aatish the fake question papers. He hopes that
Wadia will be proud of him but instead, he looks
at him in disappointment. In the morning assembly,
the students are nervous about being expelled.
But to their surprise, Wadia apologizes for not
believing in class 9F and claims that he sent the
janitor with the fake question paper. He wants to
save his student as Naina did for 9F. In the end,
the students are brought to the stage and two of
them are given the prefect badges. A year later,
the school takes part in the national science
fair competition. The students collectively
take part in it and win the first prize.
Cut to twenty-five years later, Naina is now
the principal of the school. It is her last
day as a teacher before getting retired.
When she walks out, she meets the former 9F
members who have grown into successful adults.
The movie ends as they reunite.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.